a small triumph for mep is trying to
advance european gender equality
majority supported steps designed to
bring the pay and opportunities of women
in a host of areas closer to those of
men this from the mep who steered the
file through Parliament Malcolm X yawns
plane if you enter she'd hit a man and a
natsume's plan for the steamer giveth
King frown and a Nazi ons plan for this
tema like he ain't lon anh phan frown
the prowl and guns gotta steal una
pranava Roxanne's yonin it comes as the
Commission is drawing up its 2016 to
2020 gender strategy an earlier
indicator measuring disparities in work
knowledge money time power and health
shows mountains still to be climbed out
of a possible score of 100 the EU
averages 54 parnevik artist anikartick
our Civic stout Sonia talent of ko biet
no será una zesco firm amigos padartha
it was plenty of controversy to some
mbps felt others overstepped the mark
propag we abort here yet nah ya koi
Edna's privada production in guru yevadu
kotse pops estrogen Akash nums tableau a
ducati perspective attended of a
although this is an own initiative
report offering non-binding
recommendations for new laws mep s are
hoping it'll carry plenty of persuasion
and moral authority